this is the rampart shopping network  your one-stop shop for all your fighting  needs  boy thanks for tuning in mates cross  play is here time to spiff it up  first we got the octane tuner set now  time you put some clothes on don't have  to look at that bloody midriff  my legs are ready to go but there's no  sun included  next the caustic clown set ain't great  for birthday parties  but funerals ah bloody tipped up if you  ask me  join my experiment below ah  what now oh we got the eighth cat said  hunt people down and destroy them just  like a normal house cat  and quick and i'll finish this well i'm  beaten  jonesing for sheila had the lads put  together a montage to do the rest  take it away underpaid editor  i look forward to getting my hands on  you  i am  [Music]